Haha,
I'm just gonna sit and wait for a second.
How is this happening? He was texting me that he's here.
I got Grand Central already.
Just waiting for my date to come from Grand Central
while my glasses are being held together. Potentially.
Hopefully, if we figured out by glue and gum.
Jake, do you have any thoughts?
I was strongly against the gum.
Strongly against the gum because it needed something to stick to. That.
That is the purpose of glue.
That is actually, like,
the definition. No,
but it wasn't thick. I mean, the.
The soonest from Grand Central,
probably like 20 minutes. I'm gonna paint the gum.
Oh my god! Oh my god!
It's dripping on your shirt!
Haha, okay.
But the good thing is that we got it on video.
What.
What if I kill myself?
Okay, you can stop.
Um. Update from my boob.
Awesome.
Is it coming? Is it coming?
I don't think it's. I don't think it's coming.